one man is dead or after a shooting in
the Southeast Valley this shooting
causing a lot of panic among parents at
nearby Courtney Junior High School
actually placed on lockdown because of
it Madison Kimbrough now with the
details
my granddaughter texts me and said we're
in a hard lockdown a scary afternoon at
Courtney Junior High near Hacienda and
Nellis after several students reported
hearing gunshots well they sent an email
in a text that's why I left work early
I'm like what's going on lockdown but
Metro Police confirming that the
gunshots were not on school grounds but
instead related to an incident across
the neighborhood involving two men one
of which was shot and killed sounds like
there was an altercation possibly over a
limited parking in the street cars
blocking each other which then escalated
between some residents in the area at
which time our believed suspect produced
a handgun and fired a couple rounds at
which time our victim was struck and
down on the scene Metro Police did not
reveal any other details about the
34-year-old victim as for the suspect he
is now on the Run neighbors say parking
has always been an issue in this
Southeast Valley neighborhood but for
something like this to happen it's just
maddening yeah so it's definitely only
ridiculous with the parking situation no
one knows how to talk with words anymore
it's always just result of violence in
the Southeast Valley Madison Kimbrough 8
news now we can also tell you that all
of the students and all of the teachers
at Courtney Junior High were safely
evacuated from the school